Welcome to Archon, your command center
for AI coding. It is your tool to manage
all of your knowledge and tasks for your
AI coding assistant. The big goal of
Archon is to be the one tool that
enables AI and human collaboration at a
very deep level. It's something that is
very much missing in the AI coding space
right now. So, Archon is the tool to
fill in that gap for you. for you as the
user. It is a beautiful user interface
to manage all of your projects and tasks
and all of the knowledge that you're
curating for your code bases, the
libraries that you are using. And then
for the AI coding assistant, it is an
MCP server to manage all of the same
things. So super easy to connect this to
literally any AI coding assistant. And
then you instantly give it access
through the MCP to search all of the
documentation that you've curated and
manage the same projects and tasks in
this canban board. And so for this video
right now, I've got three things for
you. First of all, I want to cover why
we actually care about using Archon in
the first place. Then a quick start. I
just want to help you in a couple of
minutes get Archon fully set up and
connected to your AI coding assistant.
And then the last thing that I want to
go through with you is a practical guide
on how to use Archon in your AI coding
workflows so that you can significantly
improve the code quality output of your
coding assistants and how easy it is for
you to manage your AI coding assistance.
So putting yourself in the driver's seat
while also still enabling your AI coding
assistance to go very far. Now first of
all why do we care about using Archon in
the first place? I mean, that's the big
question you have whenever you're
looking at a new tool, especially when
it's one related to AI and there's
millions of tools out there. Well, the
big problem that we have with AI coding
assistants right now is they take care
of too many things under the hood.
Here's what I mean by that. In our tools
that we have like Kirao or Cloud Code or
Codeex, all these coding assistants,
they have the ability to search the web.
That's their way to retrieve external
documentation. right now searching the
web for lang chain or pideantic AI all
these libraries that we're using and
they also have the ability to create
their own internal task lists so they
can organize their own work and knock
things out task by task and that's all
fine and these capabilities are quite
powerful but the problem is there's not
really a way for us to collaborate with
the AI coding assistant on these things
we can't really pick the knowledge that
it searches through because it's just
going to search the entire internet we
can't really interact with this task
list. It's more of an internal tool. You
see the problem here? It takes care of a
lot of things for us, which kind of
kicks us out of the driver's seat in
some ways that we'd really want to be a
part of the process, actually defining
the tasks and choosing the different
sources that our AI coding assistant is
going to look for to understand the
libraries that we're building with. And
that is exactly what Archon helps us
with. So, I have a little demo going on
the lefth hand side here. This is more
just mock calls to show you how archon
works at a high level. We'll really get
into the AI coding workflow in a little
bit here. And so, first of all, it's
searching my documentation, everything
that I've already curated for it in the
Archon user interface. So, I get to
point it to where to search. And so, it
pulls certain pages from the
documentation. It's performing rag under
the hood for both keyword and semantic
searching. Very, very powerful rag
strategies that we have for this. And
then I also have it set up to manage the
tasks here. here. So, we'll see in a
little bit that it's going to start
moving around these tasks and it's going
to be realtime updates for us. So, when
it uses the Archon MCP to move these
tasks around, we don't even have to
refresh our UI and we can watch it work
in real time. And we can even create our
own tasks here without even having to
interrupt Cloud Code. We can collaborate
with it because the next time it looks
at the tasks that it has to do, it'll
find those new tasks that we have
created for it. So, take a look at this
in just a second here. We'll see it move
the first task to doing. Boom. There we
go. Live updates. And it's just going to
keep going through moving all these
tasks around. It's kind of simulating
what we do in a real AI development
workflow. So there we go. It moved it to
review. And then it's going to keep
going on and on and on. Very, very cool.
And there are so many other things that
we have in store for Archon as well.
Being able to actually kick off our AI
coding assistants as background tasks in
Archon for our planning or validating
like reviewing our poll requests.
There's so many different things that we
have in store for Archon. This is just
the beginning that we have for the
knowledge and task management, but still
very very powerful. And so with that,
now that you got a good understanding of
how Archon works at a high level, allow
me to help you get it set up now
connected to your AI coding assistant in
just a few minutes. So getting started
with Archon is fairly straightforward
and most of the setup you're actually
walked through in the user interface
once you have the application up and
running. I'll show you that in a little
bit. And there are only a couple of
prerequisites that we have in this
readme which of course I'll have this
linked in the description. You'll want
Docker or Docker Desktop preferably
because Archon runs as a few different
containers. You'll want Superbase
because it's the database that powers
all of Archon. There is a free tier for
the cloud superbase. You don't even have
to pay anything. That's what I'm using
for this demonstration. And then also
local Superbase works. If you want to
host it yourself, you can do that as
well. And then you'll obviously need an
API key for an LLM provider, OpenAI. And
then we also support Gemini and Olama.
So if you want to run things 100%
locally to have your own private
knowledge base, you can do that with
Olama. And so that's another really
awesome benefit to Archon. And then to
get started, all we have to do is start
by cloning the Archon repository. And
we're using the stable branch because
that's where we have the official
releases. And so you can use the main
branch if you want something a bit more
experimental, but I'd recommend starting
with the staple branch. Then we just
change our directory into archon. And
now you can open up this folder in your
favorite code editor. Like you can do
Visual Studio Code or Windsurf or
Cursor, whatever you want to do. Go
ahead and open this up. And then we can
set up our environment variables. The
only two values we have to set right now
is our Superbase URL and service RO key.
everything else like our openi API key
for example we actually set in the
archon user interface in the settings
page we'll see in a little bit and so
going to my superbase dashboard the way
that you get these two values for cloud
superbase is you go into your project
once you have it created go to the
project settings on the lefth hand side
and then when you go to data API this is
where you can get your project URL so go
ahead and copy that and insert that for
the superbase URL and then to get your
service role key you go to API keys And
then you want to reveal and copy the
service role secret. And we want to be
in the legacy API keys tab. So go ahead
and fill out both of those things right
here. If you are running local
superbase, then usually your Superbase
URL is going to be this right here. So
host.doccker.in
pointing outside of the archon container
then with the port for your Superbase
Kong container. And then this service ro
key. You set that yourself in the
environment variables when you are
self-hosting a superbase. That is all
you have to do. Now our environment
variables are set up. Make sure you
actually do that in av file. So you'll
copy.
Rename it to env set up those values.
And now we can start the archon
containers. And actually one last thing
before we spin up archon, we need to set
up our database. And so going back to
the instructions in the readme, we just
finished our environment configuration.
Now we need to run our database setup.
And so I call up the specific file right
here that has all of the SQL you need to
run. So you just need to go to
migrations complete setup.sql. Copy the
content here. And then we'll go into our
SQL editor in Superbase. And so going
back over to Superbase, it's this tab
right here in the top left for the SQL
editor. Create a new snippet. Paste it
in and run it. This is going to create
all of our archon tables. And you don't
have to know every single table that we
need to create here, but I'd recommend
just going to the table editor and
making sure that you see a lot of Archon
tables here after you run that SQL. So,
awesome. And this is all going to be
empty now, but we're going to populate
this in a little bit when I show you
practically how to actually use archon.
So, going back to the guide here after
we have our database set up, now we can
move on to actually spinning up the
containers. And it's just a single
command. You got make sure you have
Docker installed. Once you do, it's just
a single command to spin up everything.
And so I'll go to my terminal here back
in our archon folder. Paste this in
docker compose up build-d. This is going
to build all of our archon containers at
the same time. We got one for our user
interface, one for the MCP server, and
one for all of the API endpoints. And
it's going to take a little bit to
build. So be patient. Come back in 10 to
15 minutes, and then we'll be good to
move on. All right, our containers are
built. This is what your logs should
look like if everything is working well.
You can also verify that the three
containers are up and running in Docker
Desktop. Then with that, we can go
straight to the Archon user interface
local host port 3737 by default. Those
ports are configurable as well. So you
want to bounce right to the settings
page here because you want to set up the
credentials for the LLM providers that
you want to use. And so all these are
blank by default. I'll just start by
using OpenAI right now. So I'll save all
my changes. And then I can select the
provider I want to use for both my large
language model and my embedding model.
Archon uses both under the hood for
crawling for all the documentation that
we store in our knowledge base. And so
we have quite a few different chat
providers that are available. I'm just
using OpenAI. You can select your model
and then click on save settings. Don't
forget to do that. And then after we
save the settings for the LLM, then we
can go to our embedding provider.
There's less options here because some
providers like open router don't
actually have embedding models, but we
can set each one separately. I can use
OpenAI for chat and then I could use
Olama for embeddings for example. So
select your provider here again, set the
model and then save your settings and
then boom, we are good to go. That's
everything that we have to set up in the
settings here. And then going to the MCP
tab, we have instructions for how to
connect Archon to pretty much any AI
coding assistant. I mean, we don't have
explicit instructions for every coding
assistant here, but we have a lot
covered. And any MCP compatible AI
coding assistant can connect to Archon.
So, you can kind of just copy the
instructions we have for one of the
other coding assistants. So, for cloud
code, for example, I'll go here. I'll
copy the single line. That's literally
all I have to do. Then, I'll go back to
my editor here. All I have to do is
paste this command in my terminal. And
boom, I am now connected to Archon. It
is that easy. I just get this error
because I already am connected. But then
I can do claude mcp list and this is
going to actually verify my connection
to archon. Looking really really good.
So you just have to follow whatever
process we have here based on your AI
coding assistant and then you're good to
go. The last thing that I'd recommend
doing is go back to the settings and
copy the recommended global rules that
we have for your coding assistant. So
you got one for cloud code and then one
that applies to any other AI coding
assistant. So copy this and then for
cloud code for example, you just go to
your cloud.md. I've already got this
pasted in here. And then for another AI
coding assistant like Codeex, it'd be
something like your agents.mmd. So just
follow the instructions to set up global
rules for your coding assistant and
paste this in. And this is all you need.
Your coding assistant now understands
how to use archon for the knowledge and
task management. And then upgrading
archon is also very easy. When there are
new changes you want to bring in for new
releases that we have, you just have to
pull the latest changes with git. run
the exact same docker compose command
that you ran to start things for the
first time. And then the last thing is
there's a section in the settings page
that will alert you of any migrations
that you need to run. So you can click
on a button right here, copy the SQL to
run those migrations and then you go
into the SQL editor just like we did
earlier running that to get your
database up to speed as well. That is
it. Very easy to upgrade. So with that,
you have Archon fully set up. Now quick
word from our sponsor, which is very
thematic for Archon, by the way. Then
we'll get on to how you can practically
use Archon in an AI coding workflow.
I'll show you how I approach a brand new
project, how I incorporate Archon into
it. The sponsor of today's video is none
other than Superbase themselves, which I
am pumped for because for the longest
time, they've been a core part of my
tech stack and the database that powers
all of Archon. Very thematic. They
recently had their first ever
conference, Superbase Select. That's the
video you're looking at right here. It's
the full recap, which I'll link to in
the description. and their CEO Paul
Coppstone. He kicked things off by
introducing a lot of incredible new
additions to the platform. Starting with
a remote MCP server. I've been waiting
for this one so our agents can manage
our Superbase projects without us having
to install anything. And then a lot of
new things for scalability enterprise
level in particular incorporating S3
buckets, Oreo which is a platform they
just acquired and a new open source
initiative for database orchestration
called multi-gress which is probably the
biggest thing for making superbase that
much more scalable. I really do think
that Superbase is the future of
Postgress. When they say scale the
millions they really mean it. And the
biggest takeaway that I got out of this
event is that they understand the
limitations of Postgress as the
underlying database and they're
addressing that by building things on
top of the Postgress engine while still
making it just as easy for us as the end
users to leverage Superbase. And with
that, they've got their series E for a
$100 million raise and a $5 billion
valuation, which is extremely
impressive. And last thing I'll say, if
you really want to dive into multi-gress
and see how that makes Superbase so
scalable, Sugamarine did a talk right
after Paul Coppstone where he covers
more of the core architecture. So if you
want to get more technical and see how
Superbase can really scale, definitely
check that out. And really the whole
recap is worth checking out. So link in
the description. I am always behind
Superbase and I love it as a platform.
So, this is probably the most important
part of the video, showing you how to
use Archon in an AI development
workflow. And the main point that I want
to drive across here in the next like
five minutes that I've got with you is
that it's up to you to define your own
AI coding workflow and how you want to
incorporate Archon. There's a lot of
flexibility here. I'm going to recommend
a couple of commands that I have for
reusable workflows. But you get to
decide when archon looks in the
knowledge base, when it manage tasks,
does it create the projects? Do you
create the projects for the coding
assistant first? That is all up to you
entirely. And so when I am starting a
new project or a new feature in an
existing project, the first thing I'll
do is set up my knowledge. What are the
files that I want my coding assistant to
reference or the documentation that I
want it to search through? For example,
maybe I'm building an AI agent with
Pantic AI or I'm working on some backend
that's using Superbase for the database
and I want my AI coding assistant to be
able to search through this
documentation to understand how to code
with Pantic AI or with the Superbase
SDK. So find those resources and what
you want to do is you want to go to the
documentation. So for example, I can go
to Google here and I can go superbase
documentation. There we go. I got the
superbase docs and I can actually start
by just crawling this if I want to. So I
can go to archon, click on add new
knowledge, paste in this URL and start
the crawl for any old website. This
works. However, there are a couple of
formats that are actually more optimal
for crawling. So going to superbase to
the documentation here. If I go to
llms.ext, text. Take a look at this.
Most documentation websites, if you just
append llm.ext to it, I can do the exact
same thing for Pantic AI. It has this
curated list of files that are ready to
be ingested as markdown for your AI
coding assistant. So, I'd highly
recommend looking to see if your
documentation has that, and then if it
does, copy this, go into Archon, and
then crawl this instead of just the raw
web page. I'll actually start the crawl
here so we can see this in action.
Another format that's really great is
sitemaps. And so mem zero for example,
which is a tool for agentic memory. They
have a sitemap. And so I can do
just/sitemap.xml.
This is typically how you check for a
sitemap. This is also a very good
format. So I can copy this, go into
archon, add this knowledge, start
crawling. Boom. There we go. And you can
crawl in parallel if you want to. So now
we're crawling both the MEZO and Pantic
AI documentation at the same time. And
once this crawling is complete, our
coding assistant through MCP will
immediately be able to search through
everything that we brought into our own
private knowledge base. All right, I
have both of my documentations crawled
now and I can also click in to view the
different chunks and the code examples
that we're able to search through with
the Archon MCP. And again, these can be
any URLs that you want to crawl. I would
recommend generally sticking to library
documentation, especially with the
sitemaps and the LLM.ext, but it is
quite flexible. There's a lot that you
can bring into your Archon knowledge
base. So, we've got that set up now and
we already have Archon connected through
MCP. Now, we can dive right into coding
something. Now, when I am creating code
with an AI coding assistant, I always
split things up between planning and
implementation. I even have a full video
that I'll link to right here where I go
through my general process. And there's
this really nifty Excal diagram that I
have going through how I plan things out
and then how I implement it. And I don't
do all of this from scratch every single
time. I take my general process for
planning. I package that up into a
markdown document that I have as a
reusable workflow. You can take this as
a starting point if you want. I'll have
this linked in the description as well.
But I encourage you to take my general
ideas around planning and executing and
actually build your own workflows. And
that's the thing with Archon is you get
to customize how you leverage it in your
workflows. Like for example, I have step
one, read and analyze a requirements. So
there's a specific file that I pass in
which is just what I want to build. And
I have a really simple request for this
demonstration purpose. I just want to
build a panenti agent that uses mem. So
obviously it has to leverage both of the
pieces of documentation I have in
archon. So I have it understand the
requirements first and then I have this
little research phase where it lists the
different sources that we have crawled
in archon and then it performs rag to
look through the different chunks and
code examples that we have there. And
then I do codebase analysis if it's a
feature in an existing codebase. And
then I have a plan and design. I don't
need to cover this whole markdown
because the point I'm trying to drive
home here is I just fit archon into some
part of my planning process and you can
customize this to however you want your
AI coding assistant to use archon. And
then I'm going to do the exact same
thing for the implementation phase. I'm
going to take my general process,
package it up into a command that I can
execute as a reusable workflow. And this
one specifically speaks to how to
leverage the projects and tasks within
archon. So, I tell it to look in my
global rules because this is where I'll
specify any existing projects in Archon
that I'm working on. If it doesn't find
one there, then I tell it to make a new
project and then manage all the tasks.
So, create new tasks for each of the
things that it's doing to knock out my
implementation for me. These are the
kinds of things again that you can
customize to however you want to use
Archon. And I'm going to keep saying
that over and over again because that's
the main point that I want to drive home
here. And so, I'll show you. I actually
ran the create plan already on my simple
request for the Pantic AI agent. And
here we go. It's using rag uh in Archon
to search through the chunks and the
code examples. It's doing quite a bit
analysis here. This is looking really
good. And then finally, after it reads
through all of my documentation that it
thinks it needs, it builds the plan for
me. So, I go into the PRPS folder. This
is a very simple version of PRP, by the
way, if you followed my other content in
the past. But yeah, take a look at this.
We have this full implementation plan
with all my research findings from
Archon. It's got the different tasks
that I wanted to knock out one by one.
So now when I go and actually execute
this plan, we're going to have all of
these tasks created and managed in
Archon. It is a beautiful thing. So I'm
going to come back once I have
everything executed. I'll show you how
that worked as well. All right. I just
wanted to come back mid-execution really
quick to show you that I executed my
workflow. It's starting a new project
and adding a bunch of new tasks. And so
we can see that here it created a brand
new project in Archon. The nine tasks
that I had in the plan that I created,
it converted into Archon tasks and it
moved the first one into doing to set up
the initial project structure. Very,
very nice. So, not only is it easier for
us to manage the tasks for our coding
assistant in Archon, it also gives us a
lot of observability into what's
happening. We can even click in to see
the description to kind of see a little
bit of extra details of what the coding
assistant wants to do for this specific
task. And again, we can always edit this
to change the instructions live. We can
add new tasks if we think it's missing
something. We have that flexibility to
edit things live and again determine the
workflow in the markdown document. So
I'll come back again once we have the
final implementation. Okay, our
implementation is complete. I just cut
it short of the validation here because
it's not the point to have a fully
complete solution in this video here.
But yeah, it's got all the tasks in
review. It was just about to create the
tests and then move everything into
done. So the Archon integration for the
project management is working perfectly.
And if we look at the code just really
quickly here, I can see and I I checked
this off camera already. It's looking
really good. Like it clearly understands
how to build padanti agents, how to work
with the memories with me zero. This is
the kind of thing it would not have been
able to figure out without being able to
look at the mem zero and podantic
documentation because LLMs have the
notorious training cutoff. They don't
understand these libraries and that's
why we need rag with archon for it to
write accurate code and it definitely
looks like it did. So yeah, at a high
level that's how I use archon with my
planning and my executing. Build these
workflows yourself. take inspiration
from this if you want because again I
will have these linked in the
description if you want to use these
slash commands and slash commands are
just prompts and so no matter your AI
coding assistant you can tell it to look
at this markdown document and and
execute this operation you don't have to
use cloud code like I'm using in this
demo it is just my preferred AI coding
assistant right now so that is
everything that I have for you my friend
on using archon a full guide with the
setup and how to incorporate in your AI
coding workflows I definitely want to be
putting out a lot more content on my
channel in the near future as well,
diving even deeper into incorporating
Archon into building full projects end
to end. So definitely stay tuned for
that if you're interested. If you
appreciated this video and Archon and
you're looking forward to more content
on AI coding and using Archon, I would
really appreciate a like and a
subscribe. And with that, I'll see you
in the next